you know i get messages people say pat
it's so hard making money today
you don't understand how tough things
are i'm struggling so bad and look i
understand you're struggling
but no matter how bad the economy is
there's always ways to make
money always i just heard a story a
couple days ago kid
21 22 year old kid ends up going on the
day playstation comes up buys 221
playstations
sells it a week later makes 40 000 in
one week
let me say this one more time he buys
221 playstations
for 499 dollars a piece a week later on
ebay he sells each of them between seven
hundred dollars two thousand dollars
makes forty thousand dollars in one week
now some somebody may say
you're watching the same path i don't
have a hundred thousand dollars to buy
200 playstations can you buy 20 can you
buy two
can you buy 10. let me give you a story
about myself on what happened years ago
i leave morgan stanley dean witter when
i leave morgan stanley dean with it
didn't get my license up it took six
months for me to get my license
there was a product back then before
there was smartphones this is
old school when there was no such thing
as speakers the phones didn't have
speakers
this is 2001 2002 we're talking about
this product came out called clip and
talk
these clip and talks you would clip on
your phone here
okay you'd press a button on the clip
and talk then you go to radio station
88.7
the speaker would go to your car and you
would
put it such a old-school ghetto product
but people were fascinated by this is
how it would sell out again the car was
hey john take a look at this give me
your phone
how would you like it if you can hear
whoever calls you off the radio oh my
gosh i'd be crazy
i said check this out here's a clip and
talk you put it here 88.7 make a phone
call hey mom
oh my gosh mom i can hear you people
were blown away
but the guy was trying to sell me a
thousand of them i couldn't buy a
thousand of them
but i could buy 50 of them i bought 50 i
sold them
i bought them for five bucks a pop sold
them for 20 bucks a pop
a day i sold all of them came back
bought a couple hundred
sold them back up came back bought a
thousand i sold them back that's how i
made money in one of the months when
morgan stanley dean would have wasn't
giving me
my license so i couldn't go transfer
they were taking their time with it
again moral the story hustlers are going
to find
millions of one legal ways to make money
the biggest challenge is most people
look at this and they say
oh my gosh playstation is coming out i'd
love to buy to go play playstation
and if you say oh my gosh playstation 5
is coming out
everyone's going to want to buy it it's
going to sell out you know what i'm
going to buy
50 and i'm going to sell it on ebay for
300 more
it's all perspective it's all mindset so
this
is why with 2021 being around the corner
for you
there's only one video i want you to be
thinking about to watch for 2021.
i did a video titled 20 biggest mistakes
people make when it comes down to their
business planning if you really want
your 2021
to be better than 2020 by mile and you
don't want to leave it to luck
go watch this video that talks about the
20 biggest mistakes
people make when it comes onto business
planning and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please do so have a great
week everybody take care bye